we have an academy award winner here
everybody um clean up your desk it's
basically what i'm saying you got to
clean up your workspaces we have an
academy award winner here and uh it's
it's a fun movie that uh we're talking
about that he is in available in
theaters on december 10th it's called
national champions he plays the head
coach of a college football national uh
championship team
um before the big game uh whose star
players
start a player strike because they're
not going to compete until all student
athletes are fairly compensated it's
like a little bit name image and
likeness stuff uh in many ways uh
like his law order work rips straight
from the headlines uh he is none other
than j.k simmons here in the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you jk uh i am fine how are you sir in
this in this illustrious week leading up
to
the game
and and the opening of the film of
course
[Laughter]
uh do i have to dress up for both is
what i got to do do i get a dress up for
for that well i'm i mean i'm i'm wearing
scarlet and gray face it's just
i wish uh i was in studio
uh a scarlet and gray carpet that's
being rolled out for the for the big uh
for the big uh oh god yeah i should have
i should have campaigned for that um so
i guess let's combine both of these
subject matters uh in national champions
um you play the the head coach of a of a
college football team trying to win a
national championship is it true you
demanded that your coach had to wear
khakis in this film jk
is that true would be patently false
patented
not just false just patching yes i i i
i
too late in the game i i thought oh man
i should have gone with the sweater vest
and done done a little bit of a trestle
homage but uh
uh but no we opted for a a fairly uh
dressed down uh traditional kind of polo
shirt and uh baseball cap look on uh
on my coach who i
because i was so busy leading up into
this i was
i was horrified to realize that i was
playing the head coach of the sec team
um
yeah but uh
you know
it's fiction it's fiction
well they say the sec it just means more
which outrages all of us in the big ten
when we hear that sort of phrase that it
means more to them like please
you know come on so who are you
channeling in in this role of coach
james laser jk simmons who are you
channeling as your head coach you know
what i i'm actually not channeling
anybody when i when i had an opportunity
very early in my career to play the
manager of my beloved detroit tigers
uh i unabashedly channeled jim leland
well before he was the manager of the
tigers okay
this was 1998 but uh um
he was just such a a great sort of role
model to me uh james laser is uh is just
a purely fictional creation on the part
of the writer and the director and
myself and uh
for better or worse he's he's not really
based on anybody you didn't use it as an
excuse to call up on ohio state coach
pastor president to say help me out here
you didn't use that
yeah
hey ryan day's not not busy doing
anything can he uh hang out with me for
a while
no i did not i did not take advantage
come on that would have been so cool you
know i mean it was when did we shoot
this it was uh
april was it april yeah what's april
april or may what's ryan day doing
except sending a a player to the
national football league then only to
disappoint because nobody's tom brady
[Music]
i got to hang my hat on something let's
all right so let's just jump into this
then and then we'll circle back to the
film um so
uh our what's your what's your sense of
things going into this big game jk
simmons what's your sense of ohio state
michigan
as always i am reluctant uh to uh to be
too optimistic because it is
the big game it is the big rivalry game
you know my other big rivalry that i
care about was was the brawl of the wild
which took place this past saturday the
university of montana versus montana
state
actually i actually graduated from
university of montana um
and as is often the case in rivalry
games you know montana state was the
better team coming into the game and the
university of montana just just
absolutely blew them off the field i
mean uh the defense was like a brick
wall
um
so you know i mean in a way i would like
to say come on
it's going to be you know 62 to nothing
buckeyes
because i i think we have a phenomenal
team this year and i think our defense
has
really come around
uh the last half of the season
but
i'm gonna be very cautiously optimistic
and say uh
um
you know it'll be a hard fought rivalry
game on the hostile turf and uh you know
we'll only win by a couple of countries
so because because michigan does have
something different this time around
than any of the last times that they
have faced
um you know your team and the
in the last like 15 years it yeah after
17 years right and and the difference is
in my estimation a defensive coordinator
is not going to do the same damn thing
over and over again and say try and beat
us and then when you try and then and
then you're beating five six seven
straight possessions just keep doing it
i i honestly think that michigan has a
better plan
and has the run game to maybe keep your
horses off the field to use a big sky
phrase you know so i i i absolutely
agree a better plan and and better
personnel i think um
on on both sides of the ball so yeah i
mean and honestly i mean i mean
i feel like the big brother talking to
the little brother now um which applies
i guess in a variety of ways um
i mean
i
i'm not saying this i'm not really
saying this
but in a way
it wouldn't be the worst thing in the
world even for an ohio state fan for the
team up north to to eventually win a
game again because this rivalry has
become
here's what you're doing
you're doing jk simmons i know what
you're doing i see what you're doing
you're laying the tracks of the loss
being actually good good for the rivalry
and it's good that you finally draw
blood once in a while you know like and
and as if as if you don't know that even
with this remarkable stretch run
michigan still leads the all-time series
uh by
four games that six games my bad i'm
even shorting all that so you know how
cyclical this is you know how it can be
cyclical you know
you know that well yeah in terms of you
know the first 30 years of this this was
like goliath beating up on a on a you
know
little overgrown cow town college team i
mean when this rivalry began
it was decidedly one-sided and the
wolverines were just looking for
somebody to beat up on right and then
woody hayes comes along and then
michigan takes somebody from his staff
and that's when the 10-year woody bow
war hits and then then then towards the
end of the the bow era there's when earl
bruce gets canned and then john cooper
comes in and that's when michigan was
continually beating beating them by like
a drum and then the aforementioned jim
tressel comes in things begin to flip
and then you know now things are totally
one-sided in the other direction i think
that's a fair assessment of the history
it is a very fair assessment and yeah
for me of course you know my lifetime
the rivalry you know
in my awareness began with woody hayes
so that's you know that's the sort of i
mean what's that i guess that's going on
70 years now that we're that we're
talking about the sort of quote-unquote
modern era
of the rivalry but you're not allowed to
say you know if michigan wins that's
good for the rivalry you're not allowed
to say that that is not well i'm
i wasn't allowed to say the name of that
team up north
you know
well i guess if he's so when you're
spelling your name this week it's
s-i-x-x-o-n-s
is that how you're
is that who you spell with two red x's
in the middle of your name you're not
one of those are you jk i just uh i
don't know sorry no i i don't i don't do
the x thing too much i i either refer to
them as ptun
yes that's school yep yeah the team or
or one of the one of the lang brothers
on my lang brothers buckeye chain with
my buddy and his three brothers who are
osu alumni
uh
we also routinely refer to them as
simply stupid helmets stupid
helmets he says okay that sounds really
really mature for an academy award
winner jimmy jk brothers text chain i
mean we really should fold you in on
that oh my gosh follow me and
unsubscribe jk unsubscribe in advance
yeah yeah i'll get in on that jk sixsons
here on the rich eisen show
on this big week okay so where are you
watching the game what is your scenario
for saturday uh i will be locked in uh
the uh master bedroom okay at our uh at
our place in la where we're we're sort
of
we're well we're by coastal again so but
currently in california okay so you're
you're locked now now do you need and i
by the way as is almost always the case
sometimes of necessity sometimes out of
choice
i almost never watch the game live
because i mean any ohio state game but
especially against ttun because
i just can't take it i and i can't see
you with i can't deal with the you know
three-minute commercial break yeah i
don't blame you you know i generally
started
you know if if my schedule is my own
sure i'll start it like an hour and a
half late
so that i you know by the by the end of
the game i'm i'm almost caught up to
real time
by the way and i you know yeah you got
to turn your phone off and i know you're
definitely not on social media that's
for sure so no that's i know that so
that yeah i don't blame you either
sometimes those commercial breaks are so
long half time is 45 minutes long
because you know uh the bands have to
get out there and it's the bands are you
know more important to you than me um
you know and so well because we have the
best damage
you with the bands man and the whole
script ohio which because i love the
script ohio stuff because for some
reason ohio state fans want to just
prove to the world they really can spell
you know what i mean like
you know but you get if you if we spot
you the four
four letters you can actually dot the
right one you know you want to prove
that one
well played thank you sir i appreciate
that this is fun jk simmons here uh on
the rich eisen show and and this is cool
so you are playing the william uh you
playing the actor
well you are jk simmons playing the
actor william frawley in the being the
ricardo's
film based on uh the i love lucy amazon
upcoming film being the ricardo's that's
coming up for you too next month indeed
uh on the same day as national champions
wow that is so cool what what can you
tell me about that no honestly that is
some pop culture greatness right there
what can you tell me about what to
expect uh from now uh jk well
unfortunately what what people can
expect uh because it's aaron sorkin is
not a standard biopic you know kind of
here's the spunky little eight-headed
eight-year-old redhead you know
um it's uh it basically takes a year i'm
sorry a week
in the life of lucille ball and desi
arnaz
on the
second season of i love lucy when it was
a unprecedented cultural phenomenon
um
you know half the households in the
country were tuned in on a weekly basis
and uh
and it kind of compresses several
significant events in their lives into
into one week and then of course
uh myself as bill frawley and nina
arianda as
vivian vance slash ethel mertz uh have
some really fun supporting parts in that
we have only tiny tiny glimpses of uh of
us you know in character sure
in the show the the vast majority of it
is uh is more behind the scenes
right but that must have been pretty
cool for you to to play fred mertz right
even just for a split second as the
character right i mean that was yeah it
was it was really really fun and and you
know daunting in a way uh at first and i
i
i initially
kind of shied away from it just because
you know
just because i was
being
um
[Music]
you know was afraid of you know
inadequately uh uh
sort of representing that guy but uh
right but you know after talking to
aaron who in case anybody is not aware
he's a genius
um and uh i'm talking about what what he
wanted it to be and what he didn't want
it to be and uh you know and seeing the
cast that he was putting together and
all that it was
it was a real uh a real joy to be a part
of well in the cast for national
champions as well where you again you
play a a head football coach is an
excellent cast too lil rel howery david
keckner who i love timothy oliphant
fantastic christian chenoweth and then
uh the cameos include russell wilson and
and did you get malcolm jenkins in
because he's a buckeye did you is that
how that worked
the malcolm jenkins connection happened
without me and don't forget uh stefan
james uh who plays uh
the uh heisman trophy winning uh a
quarterback yeah it's it's an amazing
cast and uh and i didn't know uh you
know what was talking about aaron but i
didn't know rick roman wa before this
the director but uh
but he was a big part of the of the uh
the attraction to me after he and i
chatted on the phone a couple times okay
and his uh his passion for uh for you
know
both uh college football and uh and
filmmaking and uh it was it was a real
uh a real labor of love on everyone's
part and and
you know a bing bang boom you know
pretty quick and intense
shoot in uh in good old new orleans
well that's good and it was it was i
mean it was actually a genius production
because you know the whole movie takes
place in that in that frenetic you know
few days building up to the national
title game and we're all staying at you
know all the press and all the and the
team you know uh are staying at the at
the grand hyatt across the street from
the mercedes-benz superdome
and that was exactly what we did i was
in new orleans for like two or three
weeks and never left the hyatt hotel
um that was uh it was like a like a like
a little uh
you know
uh
boiler
pot
boiler what's the term we were like in a
pressure cooker sure we were elected in
this pressure cooker the whole time uh
art imitating life
well uh i i you know look forward to
national champions on december 10th and
then this that's available in theaters
and then on the same day uh being the
ricardo's you play fred mertz in
theaters on on uh on on the 10th and
then of course uh and on amazon prime
the day before christmas on december
24th uh hey jk simmons i would say good
luck this weekend but i don't mean it at
all
um and um and i i think you probably uh
feel the same way if i'm not mistaken i
i do feel very much the same way i will
uh you know in a you know horribly
condescending way say good luck anyway
um because uh because i think you guys
are still the little brother and we're
still gonna smack you around okay uh
let's put a pin in that we'll put a pin
in that we shall revisit we shall
revisit yes we shall continually i hope
if not more so me too uh congrats on the
films and thanks for the call jk
all right thank you man you got a jk
simmons which is spelled with two x's
this week right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here